[Music]
let's go to oh we were coming from quad
cities and now we're just going to twin
cities minnesota let's go to emily
what's going on emily
i'm good dr don how are you i am
dancing like i've never danced before on
the ceiling in fact like the old lionel
rich what's up
um well i've got a really tough question
for you today
bring it
probably the toughest you've ever had
my husband and i are trying to navigate
santa claus
and parenting are
our kids
coming from two different uh tutors in
christian backgrounds okay so
what what is so you you and your husband
disagree on
the
what role santa claus is going to play
well yeah well i guess
whether we're going to teach our kids to
believe in santa or not god teach them
to believe you said that's so great
um
okay so
i
on the internets posted something about
never lie to your kids like it drives
you crazy never lie to your kids
and the number one question i always get
back is what about santa claus what
about santa claus what about santa claus
and so when i hit send on those things
i'm always thinking about
you know divorce and you know grief and
things like that and everyone's like
what about santa so here we go let's
answer this definitively once and for
all and
on the internets there is no once and
for all it's forever never all men okay
so
how old are your kids
uh i've got a two and a half year old
which is who we're thinking of i also
have a nine months old okay
all right so what do you want to do
well before kids i didn't want to
um teach them about santa
why not scrooge funruner.com.net
i i didn't
i didn't learn i mean i didn't believe
in santa i grew up in a really christian
home that
we didn't do halloween either so
basically just just not just no holidays
no no holidays um is that in the bible
didn't lie to us we knew about him and
you know we like we could
you know we had stockings and my parents
filled them in the morning and we just
pretend you know but it wasn't we never
believed
my husband what faith tradition are you
from
christian
my dad uh was a lutheran pastor
is that in the bible
what nobody even in sansa no i mean we
we celebrated holidays but we didn't uh
we weren't talking about santa and then
we couldn't participate in halloween it
was too much of the devil
very cool okay yeah so
yeah i wouldn't call it cool
did your do your did you dress your kids
up for halloween this year
we did yes dude you're breaking down the
barriers man
your dad has lost control of his
daughter
yeah it's going off the rails in twin
cities i love it okay
so
husband is he all in
yes okay
and i i think it's super magical but
then yeah like the line when you're two
and a half year old looks into your eyes
and asks you if wookies are real
and you're just like
no no they're not but he believes in it
so much because he heard it in a book
once
it's hard to then be like no i'm going
to teach him about santa and then
shatter his dreams at four or five years
old
that's so great
the transference of trauma from one
childhood to another is so great don't
watch it in action so good
okay so here is my thoughts on santa
claus
i believe that we have in an effort this
is all derivative from the enlightenment
we're at the back end of the
enlightenment i believe
we thought we could break everything
down into its smallest parts smallest
pieces we bought into a lie that
everything's a machine so if we took the
body apart together and all the way down
to the smallest cell we could figure it
out
and what we lost in that was
myth
we lost common stories that we told
ourselves things that bonded us together
and what we're finding out is
uh if i was just listening to andrew
huberman yesterday he's one of the
smartest men on the planet i love him
he's at stanford
talking about how people heard the same
story
and they were they listened to the story
this is a study i think it's in cell
magazine like the top top top scientific
academic journals
different people listen to the same
story in different places at different
times and their heartbeats lined up
here's what i'm getting at we are bonded
through connection not through are the
smallest pieces of us okay so here's why
that's important
i believe we have in an effort to
quantify everything to solidify
everything one of my favorite poets um
she says
um
damn the scientists for turning stars
into balls of burning gas
right we used to look up in the sky and
see these magical twinkling lights and
now they're just
sulfur and hydrogen and whatever we've
ruined them okay in an effort to take
them apart so what does that have to do
with santa claus
i'm a big believer in not stealing
stories
and common experiences and things that
are a part of us
from our kids cause the world's gonna do
that from them they're gonna take
everything from them they're gonna
they're gonna the world's gonna ruin the
greatest things about being a human
laughter and sex and joy and family and
relationships it's all gonna end up a
mess
and so man if you can create a magical
five six years with your kid
i say live every second of it
and create the
magic create the universe all that stuff
let your kids enjoy that with their
friends and their kids and then what
they'll do is over time they begin to
figure it out like wow santa claus is
like in four different places in that
mall that was weird they'll start to
figure it out and it's how they begin to
peel back the world but they do it at
their own pace at their own speed and
then there will come a moment when your
kid looks at you and says mom listen
i don't believe in this anymore or
mom i gotta ask you is this real or is
my son did
he conflated god and santa in a really
really deflating way
and so here's what i did i think i don't
remember how old he was but it's one of
my favorite moments i've had with him
i
just like out of a taster's like a
taster's choice commercial like an old
beer commercial or something i
he said something along the lines of
i'm gonna ask god for this and if god
doesn't come through i'm gonna ask for
santa i'm gonna have santa something
like that i mean it was just a total
mess
so my wife looked at me and we have the
rule in our house that whoever gets
asked the question has to answer it
so i said hank come outside with me
and i took him out this is so cheesy i
know i took him out in the back of my
pickup truck and we climbed up in the
back of the pickup truck and i said son
sometimes this is where we have hard
conversations this is where grown-ups
have hard conversations in the back of
the truck so we're gonna have one and i
just gotta level with you
and it was one of the most magical
conversations ever
and it was me saying hey i wanted you to
enjoy this i wanted you to love this
experience there was something magical
about waking up in the morning and did
we hear the rooftop all that stuff
and
i gotta level with you it was me and
your mom and i walked him through it and
then it was so great as we were getting
out he felt so big and so like it was a
great moment between us he got while i
had told him the stories and why we
wanted him to enjoy that experience how
fun it was
and then as we were leaving he goes dad
one more thing i was like yeah and he
goes
easter bunny no and i said
no son and he's like all right so we we
had the thing right and so here's the
thing it's a common myth it's a part of
us and we have just sucked that we've
made it truth or fiction kids are much
more fluid than that
and their experience of truth evolves it
moves in their participation it's the
the same thing is i'm not gonna let him
go see a movie because i don't want him
to ever think that star wars is real i'm
not gonna let him go to the theater
because i don't want him to believe in
romeo and juliet no man don't do that
don't take that from your kid is that
fair yeah that's fair i do think elf on
the shelf is from satan i think i i
agree elf on the shelf is evil it's a
way to if you're listening to this burn
your elf on the shelf burn him do you
all yourself on the shelf
we did i can see kelly's not
james you elf on the shelfer
uh not in the traditional way we kind of
like
uh do a
it's a long story we kind of like do the
elf on the shelf but we don't make it
like he's watching you you better behave
because that's kind of creepy more that
he's staring you down and judging you
no just kind of like hey you can teach
him about the christmas story or her
about the christmas story and you know
help her understand what it's all about
stuff like that and yeah we totally use
it as a threat
yeah we're like don't make us go tell
our elves was alphys
and we have like you know elvis is
watching so yeah james is a better
person
this emily is why kelly's kids will
probably be in counseling
they are
right that's right so elf on the shelf
from satan directly from satan if you
don't want your kids to do something
just tell them yourself you don't have
to like pawn it off on some toy on top
of the ceiling but
um yeah dude i i'm all in on it let him
be a part of it let him own it
and then watching my son
and like
teach the story to my daughter and let
her be a part of it it's just fun man
it's just we just gotta bring some fun
and joy back into our lives is that fair
yeah that's totally fair i don't think
it's i i don't think it's lying to kids
any more than taking them to the movies
or taking them to theater or anything
like that is there will come a moment
when they start to say well what about
the story of if you have a faith
tradition you know if you're a muslim or
if you're a christian
oh what about how does this work that's
a whole other conversation by the way
their understanding of god is going to
shift and morph over the course of their
life too like yours has right has yours
shifted and morphed
yeah yeah i see so that's part of their
journey and part of their adventure
just don't don't don't put so much
weight on this thing i'm all in on santa
so are you going to do santa or not are
you going to steal from your child i'm
skeptically kidding
no i think i think we'll do it yeah we i
mean
we were halfway in the door anyways but
then i just got cold feet i was like
do you when you listen to your husband's
stories do you feel like you missed out
um
i don't you feel like he's an idiot like
your parents sucked what lame losers no
i i i don't think either i think i
i
i felt like i knew something
that no one else like no other kid did
because they all still believed as a
child so i i was fine with it i thought
oh
it was like it was like a power move for
you it was like a flex you're like
my peasant little friends and they're
dumb they're dumb myths
but i didn't paddle at all i kept it a
secret until my friends figured it out i
had a friend named brian and i told him
it's one of the worst his mom told me to
leave his house and she should have was
one of my
wait did you not grow up believing in
santa oh no i just had an older sister
who loved ruining every every
oh you believe that idiot so she loved
that she was awesome um but i ruined it
for a friend but nope i'm all in that's
how i do it in my house i'm all in do
your kids believe in santa
yes yes but again we're
we don't like um
make it all about santa it's kind of
like and we don't also we don't like
create this
like well here's how he comes down the
chimney we're kind of like i don't know
what do you think like kind of keep it
mysterious so we're not like just
kelly you're all in yet again james is a
better parent mine did and
i have a special needs daughter who's 18
but only about five developmentally so
she still believes she's all in yeah
it's magical right yeah and even my son
now he
he plays into it now we all do it now
because she still believes yeah it's so
great the one thing that we don't have a
fireplace in my house emily and we don't
so josephine was asking and i was a
little bit creeped out at myself
explaining how he can just get in the
front door like i thought that's
probably not i mean that's gonna come
back in some counseling sessions someday
and then there was this guy that just
came in the front door and so anyway i
get that it's probably not the best
story to tell but it is where we're at
right now it's cool i might get some
deer hooves and and hit them on the
ceiling this this year we'll see